you know what's so crazy bro
is uh my son the last time you were on
my show it was like right at the
beginning of uh
i would say your viral run yeah
so my son saw it he's like yo
you had nems on your shoulder you didn't
tell me
and i was like
and i just know you because you're a
great rapper
of the disrespectful sword yeah
i said you know nems he was like yeah
the bing bong [ __ ] your life
and i was like that's crazy um so i had
to explain to my son i'm like no you
don't understand like this dude is like
a very elite level emcee
[Laughter]
do you run into that a lot now but we
was just in roscoe's and like two little
kids just came running up to me their
parents was like okay sorry we don't
want to bother you because you take a
picture i'm like
man i love it wow it's great man it's
great i just like
spent years
back in the days as a grimy individual
doing you know the wrong side of life i
made you know produced a lot of bad
karma so it's good to just
be on the right side of things and
create wherever i walk in whether it's
hardcore rappers little kids old ladies
whoever it all when i walk in they all
get happy now you know what i'm saying
which is a great thing i love it yeah i
feel like uh
it's crazy because i feel like most
people might have like a moment like the
bing bong summer with the knicks and
sidewalk talk and all that and like
not make the right moves to kind of
capitalize on that but i feel like
you've been on top of your [ __ ] bro
absolutely because you know why i've
been i've been grinding for years and
it's like i was
i always knew if i stayed consistent and
just kept on and stayed true to myself
something was gonna stick so i've been
putting in work
ready for this moment for years i didn't
know what it was gonna be just so
happens to be the bing-bong [ __ ] but i
already had [ __ ] in order
don't don't don't ever disrespect me
yeah yeah bing bong
i started
march april of
before the actual next season started
yes yes so you were already doing the
bing bong [ __ ] but it wasn't it was
actually kind of a freak
and then uh probably in like november
um it started taking off and
two months before that i had just
dropped an album with the song bing bong
right so it was perfect the song the
bing bong was just taking off right when
they started [ __ ] blowing up too at
the same time then i got the remix with
fat joe buster styles and it just was
like boom that album did this thing i
was doing the numbers you know the
videos
and then
to promote congo is when i started i was
like yo i'm not on a major i'm doing you
know everything is paid for myself i
gotta you know my albums coming out in a
week what am i going to do and i was
like
just running my hood yeah i don't
disrespect my album coming out in three
days looking like that and then by the
time the album came out
people were like yo
we kind of don't want your album to come
out because we want to keep seeing these
videos so i was like i'm gonna keep
doing them and then just went into that
and also showed people like yeah i'm not
i could i make up flash [ __ ] all the
time you thought bing bong my [ __ ] was
gonna be over when that night right when
that was yeah don't ever disrespect me
taking over bro that don't ever
disrespect me [ __ ] it's like it's like
freestyle comedy at its best it's like
freestyling without having to run
[Music]
[Laughter]
anybody ever like really get angry
um nah not really man because you know
why when i do it i'm not doing it like a
like a right like an [ __ ] like yo you
should [ __ ] don't ever dis now
i'm like yeah i don't disrespect a lot
of people don't even notice i'm doing it
to them and or they notice it after it's
already done like too late like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] don't ever disrespect
me looking like captain puerto rico
[Laughter]
yo and i'm doing it with a smile and i'm
six four three fifty right now i'm
saying like
you know what's gonna really happen yeah